two weeks ago cyclone Pam wreaked havoc
when it tore through the Vanuatu
archipelago in the South Pacific
wind speeds reached more than 300 km/h
80 percent of homes were destroyed over
160,000 people are now in need of
emergency aid
the reconstruction effort is in full
swing in the capital Port Vila now and
then even the electricity's back on but
we're told that the situation is more
severe in the north where the cyclone
hit first this is where the worst
devastation is trees everywhere have
been uprooted
roofs have been blown off the houses
along the roadside banana plantations
have been destroyed many of the roads
are now inaccessible without a
four-wheel drive
it takes us three hours to reach Takara
a small fishing village in the Northeast
we'd like to talk to the village chief
and stop to ask where we can find him
the locals speak biz lama one of the
official languages of Vanuatu this woman
points us in the direction of the beach
which is close by takara has been pretty
much devastated by cyclone Pam fields
are ravaged crops wiped out
we want to know if any relief has
arrived yet and whether any
reconstruction is underway how many how
many buildings are here how many people
the village chief shows us around he's
only 25 he succeeded his father only a
few months ago 42 I was all in here and
we've got the power
this recent disaster is a test of his
mettle this is my dad's house chief
amira house is gone away blown down with
sea and the hurricane just take off
house and we don't know where all the
stops are caught we don't know 42
families live in Takara just over 300
people many of them live off fishing
others farm the land land that the
cyclone laid waste to
only five of the villages 42 houses are
still standing all that's left of the
others is a few walls at least no one
died the locals tell us
the village chief explains that flood
water was swept up to a kilometer inland
many buildings could have withstood the
wind he says but the water battered
everything in its path Carlos Neen is a
village elder he tells us what he
remembers at the moment the storm hit my
experience is I stay in my house while I
was staying my house the cyclone was
striking the fish steel at her head the
one of the roofing flew out from the
other pelty I need my house that's the
time when I was started to find my home
way to save my life so at the time when
the cyclone would hit my the law or the
law under the roof over
I need my house I was thinking I was
part of my house and safe in other
places so at the time I went up so when
see one of my family come on and his son
fighting in their house so I know at all
the oven that though I went in and
that's where I say so three of us
staining the house and the same time we
see the timber moving we get to himand
nail started to nail the timber some of
the things that happen inside the house
you see it's early in the morning so the
heat is still bearable in the course of
the day temperatures will go up to over
40 degrees Celsius the village chief
takes us to the community center which
miraculously survived more or less
intact this is where locals keep the aid
supplies that have arrived so far the
chief tells us that for the time being
the aid workers have only brought a few
dozen liters of drinking water and sixth
are pollens yeah only under litres of
water not in an touched it that's family
he's disappointed by a organisations and
the government which promised rapid
relief he feels he's been left in the
lurch the water supplies will only last
another few days Roger and his family
lived close by his friends are helping
him rebuild his home but he can only get
building materials in the capital and he
can't afford them anyway Roger is a
fisherman he makes his living selling
barracudas and tuna fortunately his boat
survived the cyclone unscathed but
before he can return to work the village
needs to be cleaned up sand and garbage
washed up in the flood is a major
problem in some places it's half a meter
high
Roger is digging his way through the
sand in the hope of finding at least
some of his and his family's belongings
everything they owned is buried under
the sand like spoons and blades and fork
and some pros are you missing some some
precious things some things of value
yeah like cherries and for my wife Roger
and his family are relying on the
kindness of others they have few savings
and the money they do have they need for
food he's bought rice and fish
one of his daughters finds a photograph
that means a lot to him and his wife
you found it it's a picture of my my
family but she found it and gave it to
me
everyone here is doing their best to
make do and return to normality as soon
as possible but many families are still
having to sleep outside
a few turbulence have been set up here
and there mainly as protection against
the scorching Sun right now the most
urgent problem is the lack of drinking
water
only a few leaders are left
locals have resorted to boiling water
from the nearby river Roy is one of
Rogers neighbors this is the second
severe cyclone he's experienced the
second just a take away my planet half
of my house so I tried to repent for my
house again so there's no enough
material but we try to look for all nail
and Timbers too trendy
even children are helping with the
reconstruction effort for example
collecting useful bits and pieces to
help rebuild
there's no school for the time being
every single school in the region was
destroyed by cyclone Pam here in Takara
locals think it will take four to six
weeks to repair the worst of the damage
but many families tell us they wonder if
it makes sense to rebuild their homes
they're increasingly worried about
living so close to the coast climate
change means water levels are rising how
many more years can the village survive
here
the village chief and the village elder
know that climate change is a growing
threat and you have the feeling that the
weather is changing from November up to
April is the cyclone like cyclone season
so at the moment you should be a light
which is slowly but you are experiencing
that the sea is coming up what can you
do about that in the future yeah we're
trying to maybe we're trying to move up
to make a new location so we must stay
far from the coast and that is maybe we
can the sea will cannot come and spoil
everything like houses or whatever they
still hold out hope that climate change
can be curbed Vanuatu's president
Baldwin Lonsdale has already warned that
if it isn't Vanuatu might one day become
uninhabitable he said last week that
climate change was a key factor in the
devastation brought on the Pacific
nation by super cyclone Pam
Carlos Neen tells us that hurricanes
happen here frequently and that the
authorities usually give the villagers
plenty of warning but the full force of
this recent cyclone was tragically
underestimated the weather like cyclone
Pam is too strong and it too much
everything everything everything goes
down yeah
for now all they can do here in Takara
is wait for more aid
and we need to get back to Port Vila the
government has introduced a curfew to
prevent looting two weeks after cyclone
Pam struck Vanuatu is still in a state
of emergency